son las elecciones presidenciales más
competidas en las últimas tres décadas
en angola unos 14,4 millones de votantes
deberán elegir entre las ocho
formaciones que pugnan por los 220
escaños de la asamblea nacional sin
embargo sólo dos partidos tienen
opciones de alcanzar la presidencia en
esta votación el gobernante movimiento
popular de liberación de angola liderado
por joão lourenço en el poder desde 2017
que busca la reelección y la unidad
nacional para la independencia total de
angola principal partido opositor
encabezado por alberto costa júnior el
próximo presidente deberá hacer frente a
una inflación galopante al desempleo y a
la peor sequía de los últimos 40 años
la tasa de desempleo es bastante amplia
y el modo de vida es precario hay una
revuelta en la mente de los jóvenes
sobre todo de aquellos que soñaban con
una nueva angola que no existe
lorenzo un militar de alto rango ha sido
criticado por no atajar los altos
niveles de inflación pobreza y desempleo
en el país a pesar de que angola es el
segundo productor de petróleo de áfrica
algo que promete su contrincante costa
júnior además de crear puestos de
trabajo pero a pesar de estas promesas
los sondeos dan como favorito al partido
gobernante aunque por un estrecho margen
y es que el mp le ha mantenido su
control sobre el proceso electoral y los
medios de comunicación públicos en
angola por lo que las acusaciones de
fraude se han multiplicado en el período
previo a los comicios
para que voy a votar el voto ya está
decidido ya sabemos quién va a ganar las
elecciones
los resultados se esperan para dentro de
unos días si el perdedor acude a la
impugnación el proceso podría durar
varias semanas